cocorico ises que les chroniqueurs et
les invités connaissent la france le
principe est simple une question sur la
france alors ccc d'un côté vous camille
qui me donner la réponse
vous vous concerter une bonne réponse un
point une mauvaise réponse le point à
l'adversaire et après je pars sur
l'espace nul alors attention avec par
camille mais auparavant je précise que
l'équipe gagnante choisira chroniqueur
chez les perdants qui devra aller
s'habiller en quelqu'un qui symbolise
vraiment la france j'ai nommé geneviève
de fontenay
voici votre question en 2015
où sont passés les cyclistes par où sont
passés les cyclistes du tour de france
est-ce qu'ils sont passés par rennes s
qui sont passé par bordeaux
est-ce qu'ils sont passés par strasbourg
il ya une seule bonne réponse évidemment
où est-ce qu'ils sont passés par la
pharmacie de p&o en valoir une blague de
nos auteurs alors moi j'ai dans mon
extrait on a vu que j'étais pas calé en
sport elle nous dit rehn ils ne sont pas
passés par bordeaux pas par strasbourg
ou pas par la pharmacie et d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire parce qu'anna un
plus qui ne se doutent pas qu'ils se
dopent qu'il faut quand même le faire
ok non mais c'est la vérité faut leur
rendre hommage à ces des surhommes ils
sont passés par n le faire sûr que vous
allez être excellent kit eco coaticook
au concasseur de cacao qui file à côté
mais beaucoup qu'aucun le concasseur de
cacao a remarqué caracolant caduque et
cacochyme conquis par les coquins kaka
de kiki la coke autocratique et la
cocotte à coquelles karanka qui
accueille deux cargos concasseur de
cacao saveurs sucrées qui la conquête
aperçu du marquis caracolant caduc à
cauchy à coca coca qui accole de cacao
icco conclut je crois mon cas je suis le
cocu
[Applaudissements]
quel est le nom de la spécialité
ardennaise à base de pommes de terre de
l'art et d'oignons
c'est évidemment et vous le savez
camille le chou du trou que c'est la
marive elle qui fouette c'est la cacasse
à cul nu ou c'est le steeple bouffe trop
tu auras gros cul c'est un beauf trop
tôt un gros cul pour la dea et vous
pensez mais perdu en effet alors le chou
du trou la marive elle qui fouette la
cacasse à cul nu laquelle tout le sinaï
la cacasse à cul bien j'ai fait une
mauvaise réponse est de 3 à 2 critical
path écho casper de cacau qui la cocotte
aimait beaucoup collomb le concasseur de
cacao au grand marnier caracolant
caduque et cacochyme conquis par les
coquins qu'en cas de clic et la cocotte
fait qu'un ticket la cocotte un coq et
caraco cas qu'ils accolent de caracul
cancon que le concasseur de cacao sa
plastique et la cocotte avait reçu des
marques qui caracole en tête du cac
après l'hymne à cô té ka rackauckas qui
a collé quelques coquilles en plus je
commande était aussi cocu
[Applaudissements]
attention vous pouvez maintenant tout
gagner déchirée et devenir une idole je
vous pose la question la voici qu'elle
était la particularité de louis xv
harvey a il avait les pieds palmés louis
il avait un estomac deux fois plus grand
que la moyenne il était dyslexique où il
avait un coran h d'après cristina
cordula si kubica répond si vous dites
dyslexie comme il ya déjà 3 2 ap 2 est
bien la bonne réponse c'est qu'il avait
un estomac deux fois plus grand qu'un
moyen donc vous donner le point et nous
nous retrouvons là je pensais que trois
partout a eu une mauvaise lumière
bleutée cocotte ecocup les cocottes
ekoko concasseur de cacao kiki la
cocotte et m'aide beaucoup kokolo
concasseur de cacao au maquis carcan
cocu dernière question la voici vous
pouvez tout gagner mais nous n'avons
qu'une minute pour ça me dit tout repart
comme en hurlant dans l'oreille qu'elle
scientifiques français est à l'origine
de la loi physique rien ne se perd rien
ne se crée tout se transforme
blaise pascal antoine de lavoisier -
nicolas appert quai des rêves éveillés
ou des talents
[Applaudissements]
rivages
jolie bien de fond que laurence pinet
vous voir en geneviève de fontenay pas
estelle non plus parce qu'elle était
très copine avec geneviève de fontenay
doublement pas lui faire c'est me
soumettre aux jeunes rives deux sont nés
qui lèvent la main
à l'évidence c'est très attaché je vous
un super départ je m'excuse j'ai donné
un mois dans les déguisements je
l'utilisé pas sympa je sais pas si
j'aimerais être à sa place ou pas mais
je ne regrette pas une seule image et
ses deux filles que vous me disiez à nos
deux invités qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
alors oui au moins merci camille ya qu
un truc qui me fait cesser la banane a
plus qu'eux